[MUSIC PLAYING]
KOBI MAGNEZI: Welcome to
GKE Releases Management
and Strategy session.
My name is Kobi Magnezi I'm
a product manager for GKE,
Google Kubernetes Engine.
And I have the pleasure
to have here with me
Josh Hoak, Zach Loafman,
and Daniel Loreto.
We are going to speak about
non-trivial challenges
that we have with
managing GKE at scale
and managing different
releases of Kubernetes
at scale in the GKE fleet.
What can you expect
from this session today?
One, we are going to start with
just a quick overview of Google
Kubernetes Engine, the way we
manage the different building
blocks of Kubernetes
in the fleet.
Two, we are going to speak
about some challenges.
Those challenges
present some limitation,
but also entice us to
think about different ways
we can simplify and streamline
the release process for you.
Three, we are going to speak
about Kubernetes at scale.
How do we take an open
source Kubernetes version,
and funnel it through
the power engine of GKE,
and make it available for you?
Four, we are going to speak
about tools and capabilities
that we provide you, so
you can manage your risk,
and you can manage
your clusters.
And then, five,
lastly, we are going
to share with you some of
the upcoming features that
will give you more flexibility
and control over the GKE
releases.
In this Google
Next event, we also
introduced a new
capability, so the Dory Q&A.
You've probably seen it
in different sessions.
Feel free to open your
app-- the Google Next app.
You can find the link to the
Dory Q&A under our session.
You can submit questions
now or after the session.
We are also going to
have two microphone here,
and you can ask your question
using one of these microphone.
We have a moderator here that
will help get the questions
that you posed online.
And so after this
session, we'll go
through some of these question.
So let's start with a quick
introduction into GKE.
Josh.
JOSH HOAK: Cool, thanks, Kobi.
So I work on fleet management
and a lot on the releases.
So I'm going to first
start with, what is GKE?
I know you've heard a
lot about Kubernetes.
But just so everyone's
on the same page,
I'm going to talk a little
bit about Kubernetes
in Google Kubernetes Engine.
So I said two things.
Google Kubernetes Engine
is a Google Cloud Service.
It's that box within a box.
And then you have Kubernetes,
which is a container management
system.
You might have heard, it
orchestrates containers.
And typically, when
I think container,
I'm thinking Docker containers.
And I'm thinking things like
rollback, and deployment,
and scheduling, and
stuff like that.
Google Kubernetes service
is a Google Cloud Service,
just like many of our
Google Cloud Services.
You can interact with it
via the API, CLI, or UI.
But Kubernetes is like
a heterogeneous thing.
And when I think
about Kubernetes,
it has two big parts.
It has the Kubernetes
master, and it
has the Kubernetes nodes.
And the Kubernetes nodes are
where users run workloads.
And then the
Kubernetes master is
where we run all the little
tiny pieces that make up
the Kubernetes control
plane, if you will,
that manage Kubernetes.
So we, Google, are in charge
of managing your master,
and you are in charge
of managing your nodes.
And there's many
different things
you can do for your nodes.
You can opt into
node auto-upgrade.
But ultimately, it's
your responsibility.
So after you've
created a cluster,
now you have something
that you can interact with.
And you can interact
with kubectl,
and you can create
pods and deployments,
and so on, or you
can use the API.
So now, I'm going
to pass it to Zach.
And Zach's going to
talk a little bit more
about the internals
of Kubernetes.
ZACH LOAFMAN: Hey.
Thanks, Josh.
So as Josh alluded to, I'm
going to give you a little look
under the hood for Kubernetes.
This is super-basic.
The basic Kubernetes
architecture
is that you have
these containers.
As Josh said, these
are Docker containers.
You have pods, which
are collections
of these containers, nodes
that those pods are running
on that then talk to a master,
which controls the cluster,
it and uses etcd as
its backing store.
But that simplistic
view hides a fair amount
of complexity of things that we
manage for you under the hood.
We run almost 50 different
Docker images on the master.
This slide is just a sample.
They include obvious
things, like the API server.
You might be familiar with the
Kube API server here, etcd.
We run all of those
on top of kubelet,
but they also include
other things on the master,
like support pods for
logging, and monitoring,
and metrics, networking,
scheduling, et cetera.
We also manage the software that
runs on the nodes, including
the OS image in kubelet.
And as part of the
master version, which
we'll get into in
just a little bit,
we manage the series of add-ons.
This includes support for
logging and monitoring
of your pods and also things
like Istio and Knative as well.
And on the nodes is,
obviously, your application
as well running on top of
our OS image in kubelet.
And now, I'm going to pass it
over to Kobi to talk about some
of our challenges here.
KOBI MAGNEZI: Thanks.
So Kubernetes is indeed
a very powerful framework
and platform.
It's basically a
microservices framework
built on top of
microservices-- pretty awesome.
But with all these large
set of building blocks,
we face the challenges of
coordinating and qualifying
different releases.
Going through these
specific challenges,
I think it will
help us understand
the reasons and the
drivers we have to simplify
the process for you guys.
So Kubernetes communities
is a super-engage community.
It drives lots of code changes.
This, in turn, translate
to quarterly releases
of the open source
Kubernetes version.
On top of those
quarterly-released version,
there are patch versions,
which include some bug fixes.
And there is also
GKE patch releases,
which includes, basically,
the magic glue that we
have to integrate
Kubernetes with the GCP
infrastructure,
which then, in turn,
allows you to use
GCP capabilities
through Kubernetes.
For example, you can use GCP
preemtible VM as Preemtible VM
under Kubernetes cluster.
In this specific example, you
can see the amount of version
that we basically support
in the fleet right now.
So if you open up a
gcloud command line
and query the least of versions
that we support, and you
can actually ask for
a specific region,
you will see what version
we support from the nodes
and what version we
support for the master
in every specific
geographical location.
So that's definitely
one challenge
having these amount of
versions to support.
The other thing that
we need to take care of
is the version skew policy.
So the open source
Kubernetes policy
supports two minor versions.
So let's take 1.14.
That's the latest version.
When 1.14 becomes
available in the market,
the official support would
be for 1.13 and 1.12.
However, it doesn't
really end there.
As you probably remember
from the explanation we just
got from Josh and Zach,
there are two main components
for every Kubernetes cluster.
There is the master,
and there is the node.
And each one of them, you
can have different versions.
Obviously, we encourage you
and we want our customers
to have the same version in
both the master and the nodes.
But the supported
version skew allow
nodes to be up to two minor
versions older than the master.
In the next challenge,
the final one--
probably the more crucial one--
are security fixes.
And obviously, the
sense of urgency
to roll out these
security features,
security patches is
higher, especially when
there are some critical
issues, like the one we just
experienced last December.
So you don't need
to lean forward to--
I know it's kind
of an eye chart.
But in this case, there
was a security issue
with the Kubernetes API.
We patched it, and we
quickly rolled it out
to the entire cluster.
So no action was actually
required from our customers.
If you used GKE, you
benefit from the rollout
of these patches.
In these cases-- in the
security issue cases--
GKE team will do their best to
identify, resolve, and patch
the entire fleet
and your clusters
as well to keep your
workloads safe and secure.
For GKE as a managed
Kubernetes service,
we strive to remove
that level of complexity
that I just described.
And how we deal with
all these challenges,
Josh is going to
give us some details.
JOSH HOAK: Cool.
So really, when I think about
release of Kubernetes in GKE,
I'm really talking about, how do
we get the open source software
into Google Kubernetes Engine?
And I see it as having,
like, five main phases.
So the first phase is the
open source release happens.
And I'm going to [? lite ?]
a lot of stuff here.
But the open source release
is quite complicated.
I mean, there's a whole process
of release qualification,
and you have to
write release notes.
Kubernetes has these
special interest groups
that are a sort of federated
way that features are created,
and all these people
have to get together.
But from my perspective,
working on GKE,
you kind of wait for
that process to finish.
And then-- boom-- they come
out with a new version.
Then we import that
version internally,
and we start applying our
patches on top of that.
After that, then we
qualify the version.
And this can be quite
a long period of time,
sometimes weeks or
months, depending
on what the version is.
And then, at some
point, we're like, OK,
it is time to release
a new version.
Let's cut a release candidate.
So we cut a release
candidate, and then
that period is about,
roughly, one to two weeks.
And then we roll it out
to production, of course,
assuming everything
works perfectly.
And then once it rolls
out to production,
we actually have a
four-day rollout period.
So we roll it out to a
couple locations first
and a couple locations next,
well, more than a couple.
And then we gradually
do all the locations.
And we try to put this
all in our release notes.
Now, of course, these days
might not happen sequentially.
We might pause it if
we find an outage,
and then fix the outage
before we proceed on.
But this is sort of
the sequential order.
So what are we releasing?
When you see, oh,
we're releasing
a new version of
Kubernetes, this
is kind of what
Kobi was getting to.
We have these four
different version numbers.
So we got the minor version.
We have the Kubernetes patch.
So those both come
from upstream.
And then we have the
GKE-specific patch, which
is what we're adding on top.
And what corresponds to that?
This is kind of our
identifier for the software.
This is the collection of
software that we release--
the OS image, Kube API server,
Kubelet logging, whatever.
So it's a very important number.
And remember, we
have two versions.
We have the master version,
and we have the node version.
And those are separate,
again, because of this shared
responsibility, where
we own the master,
and we are sort of
in charge of that.
I mean, you can upgrade your
master if you want on your own,
but we will do it eventually
for everyone, if you wait.
And then there's the
nodes, which you can opt in
to node auto-upgrades.
But ultimately, it's
your responsibility.
And we have to sort of
manage these things.
That gets into upgrades.
How do we upgrade the fleet for
both the masters and the nodes?
And Zack's going to talk
a little bit about that.
ZACH LOAFMAN: Cool.
Thanks.
Most of the users of GKE,
[? i.e. you, ?] experience
our release process
during upgrades,
whether it's a master
upgrade, which we initiate,
or whether it's a node upgrade,
which you have the option
of initiating yourself
or managing through us.
So first, let's talk
about the masters.
Master upgrades are managed--
and like I mentioned--
typically initiated
as part of the GKE
release process.
Workloads running
on user nodes just
stay running during the
master upgrade process.
When we upgrade
the control plane,
we also upgrade all of our
managed add-ons as well.
So as you can see
in this picture,
the master is upgraded along
with the versions for Istio,
Knative, and, as I
mentioned before,
all those logging and monitoring
and metrics support add-ons,
all while your user
application is running.
How do we do it?
We upgrade zonal
masters in place
by creating a new master
with new software.
Then we shift the
disk and network over,
and we kill the old master.
We do this pattern
for zonal masters.
For regional
masters, where there
are three HA masters running,
we do a very similar pattern,
where we spin up
one more master.
And then we kind of roll
through doing a rolling update
on the masters.
So node upgrades-- node upgrades
are a very similar process,
but they're more visible to you.
In GKE today, you
can actually choose
who manages the node upgrade.
And I'll get more into
that in a little bit.
But if you have node
auto-upgrade turned on,
you we will initiate the
node upgrades for you.
And if not, you will
initiate them yourself.
So how does a node upgrade work?
Well, it's actually a very
similar rolling update process.
What we do is we create a
new node at the new version.
We cordon off and
drain the old node.
The workload shifts
scheduling to the new node,
and then we kill
off the old node.
This actually isn't
exactly right.
What I just showed you was a
feature we have coming up soon,
called surge upgrades,
where we will actually
give you the capacity for
one more node as you're
doing the upgrade.
Currently, the way
the picture works
is, we cordon and
drain an existing node,
and then add that back in
after we've deleted it.
So over to Josh to talk
about the version lifecycle.
JOSH HOAK: Cool.
So you might be wondering, why
do we have so many versions?
And part of that is just
the natural lifecycle
of the versions and
really how it relates
to this upgrade process.
So I'm going to first talk about
minor versions of Kubernetes,
even though, in many
ways, the minor version
is kind of the major version.
But it's sort of the feature
version of Kubernetes.
Because that's what
most people care about.
All right, so what does
it look like in my head,
and how do we sequence this?
Well, normally,
what happens is when
we release a new
minor version, there's
a period time when
it's a new version.
And what that means is,
it's available for you
to choose to use.
But it's not default,
and so you can
use this to use new features
for GPUs, or TPUs, or whatever.
At some point, after
about maybe a quarter,
we decide to make that
the default. We're like,
OK, we're pretty
sure that this is
a solid enough version for the
entire fleet of GKE clusters.
And then when we shift over the
default to the next version,
now we start to phase
out the old minor version
of Kubernetes.
So now, that gets into upgrades.
When do we do upgrades?
We do this in the
phase-out period.
So during that
third-period time is
when we start to do
the master upgrades.
And we upgrade
everything that was
the default, but is
no longer the default,
to the new default.
Sometime after
that, we upgrade the
nodes to the new node
version for those
customers that have
the node auto-upgrade enabled.
And patches work
very, very similarly,
except that the phase
is much, much shorter.
So typically, for
a patch, we're not
talking about the order of
weeks rather than quarters.
So we release a new patch, and
then we migrate people over.
And it sort of happens
in rapid succession,
because patches are our bug
fixes and less invasive.
And that's about it for
the version lifecycle.
So now, I'm going
to pass it over
to Kobi to talk about how
you can manage your risk.
KOBI MAGNEZI: Thanks.
So now that you have
visibility into kind
of the behind-the-scene process
of how we release Kubernetes
and the strategy
we have, I think
it's important to know what
controls you have today,
control that enable
you to manage risk
and also control the disruption.
I would say, the
first thing that
might be pretty obvious, but
transparency is key for us.
And actually, we
want to make sure
that we provide you with
visibility into our release
scope, the schedule,
and the lifecycle.
Our release notes include
more than just change log.
We actually publish information
about upcoming versions,
the lifecycle versions
that we are duplicating,
and even more than that.
I think I saw someone taking a
picture before of their release
cadence in different regions.
We actually publish it.
That's part of
the release notes.
So if you go into
the release notes,
you can see exactly the
four days rollout schedule
and in which region we are
releasing a version first
and kind of get more
information that you
can use to plan your
Kubernetes clusters.
JOSH HOAK: Yeah, and as Kobi
said, picking a location
is important.
The day 1 zones happen first.
And typically, the big
outages-- if they happen, which,
hopefully, they don't-- we catch
them in day 1 and day 2 zones
and regions.
Additionally, like
I was alluding to
and maybe you figured out,
it's important to think
a little bit about which
version you're picking.
If you want the latest and
greatest Kubernetes features
or Google Cloud
features that come
with the new version
of Kubernetes on GKE,
choose the latest version.
But we are very careful about
only setting the default when
we think it's the right
time, when we think
this is the version that
the majority of the fleet
should be on.
ZACH LOAFMAN: While you're
thinking about the version,
another configuration to think
about is node auto-upgrade.
As I alluded to
earlier, either you
can manage your node
upgrades yourself,
or you can have us manage them.
With node auto-upgrade
enabled, anytime
that we do a master
upgrade, shortly after,
we will upgrade all
of your nodes as well.
We highly recommend
you enable this.
If you don't, it's
your responsibility
to stay within the two
minor version skew policy
that we have.
The node auto-upgrade
feature is actually default
now in the Cloud Console,
which is the example you'll
see on the right.
And it will soon be the
default in G Cloud as well.
So we take various automated
actions on our clusters.
And we recognize that
some of those actions,
like node upgrades, might cause
disruptions to your workload
or carry some risk
associated with them.
So if there are
times of day that
might make more sense for
you to perform upgrades,
you can configure
maintenance windows
to stop automated actions on
your cluster for those Windows.
And there's an example for
how to configure a maintenance
window up here and
more documentation.
And now, over to Kobi
to talk about customers.
KOBI MAGNEZI: So
with that in mind,
I invite Daniel to share more
about their experience as GKE
customer and tell us
more about their product
and their business needs.
DANIEL LORETO: Thank you, Kobi.
My name is Daniel.
I'm the head of
engineering at Virta.
I wanted to share with
you how we use GKE
or why we chose it as
our runtime platform.
But first, let me
give you a little bit
of context about Virta.
Virta is a company
that provides,
essentially, continuous
remote care for diabetes.
And so we use technology
to be able to provide
24/7 care to our patients.
We have clinically-proven
results.
And through technology, we
can scale that treatment
to lots of patients.
Providing care
through technology
is a challenging area.
We need to maintain a
doctor-patient relationship
through technology
asynchronously.
Many of our customers
are very risk-averse.
We're dealing with health care.
People's lives and
health are at stake.
And so downtime or a bug could
have serious adverse effects.
And we're working in a very
heavily-regulated industry
with regulations, such as HIPAA.
And so part of why we choose
GKE as a runtime environment
is because it makes some
of our concerns easier.
GCP is a high-trust
certified platform.
That's an important
certification in health care.
And a lot of those controls,
we're able to inherit.
And we have a shared
responsibility model,
where we're able to meet the
necessary regulation, in part,
thanks to the help
that Google provides.
Security updates--
super-important for us.
And the fact that Google
can do that for us takes
a lot of that burden away,
so that our engineering team
doesn't have to worry about it.
And making running a
GKE cluster easier,
essentially, removes a
lot of operational cost.
So our engineers can focus
on business needs as opposed
to maintaining the
infrastructure.
That said, there's
also challenges
we've experienced,
particularly around managing
all the different GKE versions.
So for example,
sometimes we want
to have the cutting-edge
version in certain clusters.
So our developers
are experimenting
with the latest version,
but a more stable version
in production.
Sometimes we're ready to
roll out a certain GKE
version to production, and so we
have a pre-production cluster.
And we have to manage
that upgrade of versions
all the way to production.
And we want to be fairly
careful also with the windows
in which we do this.
So we mentioned earlier, there's
a maintenance window feature.
But today, that
allows you to specify
four-hour windows in which
you want to load the updates.
We love a little bit more
flexibility with that.
For example, avoiding
it during weekends.
Or sometimes we
assign a customer,
and we're going to have
a big spike of patients.
And so we'd like to avoid
upgrades during that window.
And so back to Kobi,
who's going to talk
about how those challenges
relate to different customer
personas.
KOBI MAGNEZI: Thank you.
So we just heard from Virta,
and thanks for sharing
your experience with us.
Evidently, one size
doesn't necessarily
fit all, even though we're
talking about managed cloud
service.
Different customers
have different needs.
And I want to share with
you some other examples.
So we heard about Virta.
We actually created
some customer persona
to represent different
needs from different type
of customers.
So in this case,
customer A, they
have a specific multi-weeks
certification process
for every release.
And they have to go
through that process
and certify that release
before they roll it out
into production.
They're using GKE
today, and they
are looking to align their
internal certification
process with the GKE releases.
Another example would
be this customer.
They upgrade today manually.
So even though we have
the auto-upgrade option,
they decided to upgrade
manually, because they
want better control.
And they want to make sure
that they understand what they
are getting in every release.
They are definitely
excited about the ability
to test early
version of Kubernetes
and get better time to
market with new capabilities.
And in this case, this type
of customer, customer C,
they are pretty self-sufficient.
They know Kubernetes
pretty well.
They feel very
comfortable with it.
They want to adopt new
feature quickly and maybe even
be on the bleeding edge
version of the Kubernetes.
But they also want
the ability to manage
different environments
and maybe have
different type of versions in
each one of these environments.
So with this example
in mind, we are
excited to share with you some
of our upcoming capabilities
that will, one, provide you
more control and flexibility,
and two, will allow us to
cater to different types
of customers.
ZACH LOAFMAN: An exciting
feature we have coming up in Q2
is release channels.
Release channels will allow
you to subscribe your cluster
to releases that match your
release cadence and risk
profile, keeping the
masters and nodes together
at the channel that's
just right for you.
Our goal is that every
change is qualified
in an earlier channel before
it moves to a later channel.
So for example, any change that
made it to this regular channel
would have been
qualified previously
in the rapid channel.
Soon, we'll release
the rapid channel,
where you can expect the
latest and greatest releases.
Later this year, we will follow
with the regular channel--
bundled and qualified pieces
from the rapid channel--
with a stable
channel soon after.
We expect that most
of you will want
the rapid or regular channels.
But if you need our most
stable but least feature-full
releases, the stable
channel is for you.
There's a simple example here.
Soon, you'll be able to
create a release channel
cluster with as straightforward
a command line as just saying,
release channel rapid.
And we'll follow with Cloud
Console changes later, too.
And you'll get a cluster whose
master nodes are maintained
at the newest release that we've
qualified internally for GKE.
This will be available later
this quarter, hopefully.
JOSH HOAK: Cool.
So this is something I'm
very passionate about.
One of the things that I've
been working on is the release.
And as part of release channels,
we want more granular releases,
at least internally.
And we've been making a lot of
new tooling and infrastructure.
And some of that's provided
in this new open source
repository we created
called the Cluster Bundle.
So if you're curious
kind of like how
we think about
releasing components,
definitely check it out.
What is that going to
mean for customers?
You won't see it
directly, but you'll
see it in the form of
more stable releases,
improved time to market,
and better release nodes.
KOBI MAGNEZI: So in
addition to release channels
we just discussed,
release channels
allow you to inform us
with your risk appetite
and kind of the type
of version or release
you want to subscribe
to your cluster to.
We also want to support you in
managing your risk or your risk
mitigation plans, and canary
cluster can help with that.
A canary cluster will
allow you to designate
a cluster for canary or
staging test and blink it
or map it with your production
cluster or clusters.
In turn, what we will do is
GKE will sequence new version
rollout to canary
clusters first.
And we'll give you some time
to run your automate test,
make sure that
everything works, nothing
breaks with the new version.
And once you greenlight
that version,
we will roll out the new
version to production.
The other thing we are going to
do as an alpha feature coming
up from product is enhanced
maintenance windows,
which we just spoke about.
So right now, with
maintenance windows,
you can specify four hours in
a day that we will respect,
and we will trigger
maintenance events only
in these four hours.
But we do hear from
other customers
that there are other use cases
that they want us to support.
For example, if you prefer to
avoid upgrade during weekends,
because you a gaming
company, and most
of the traffic you're getting
is actually during the weekend,
you will be able to use
enhanced maintenance windows
and set the specific
days that you
want us to avoid those upgrades
or those maintenance events.
Other use case might
be you are a retailer,
and you want to make sure
that we don't disrupt you
with any type of
maintenance events
during Black Friday,
Cyber Monday.
So you'll be able to
specify a range of dates
that we will respect.
And we will avoid
maintenance windows
happening in these dates.
Now the last use
case is, let's say,
you know about upcoming upgrade.
But for some
internal reasons, you
need more time to get ready
for that specific upgrade.
We will allow you to
postpone or snooze
the upgrade for a
specific amount of time
to kind of give you more
flexibility in getting
ready for consuming the upgrade.
So just bring all of this
together, because we definitely
spoke about a lot of
things in this session,
our goal is to keep your cluster
up and running, up to date,
while delivering a
non-disruptive experience
for your customers
and for your clusters.
We aim to provide a
hassle-free managed service.
That's only on one side.
And the other side
is we're trying
to balance that with give you
more controls for flexibility.
If you are interested in
any one of the feature
that I just mentioned
that we spoke about today,
please follow that
link over there.
And let us know that you want to
join one of the alpha programs
that I mentioned.
Your feedback is
highly appreciated
as with any other sessions.
So after this session and
after we're done with the Q&A,
please take a moment
to go through the app
and share your experience
with this session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]